밀도 행렬에서는 그렇지 않아요. 여기서는 더 흥미로운 것들이 있어요. 예를 들어, 밀도 행렬로 상관된 고전적 상태를 설명할 수 있어요.
여기 Alice와 Bob이 공유하는 고전적 무작위 비트를 나타내는 밀도 행렬의 예시가 있어요.
이들은 항상 같은 고전적 상태, 0 또는 1을 가지고, 각 경우의 확률은
1/2이에요. 이건 얽힌 상태가 아니에요. 얽힘은 비고전적이에요. 하지만
상관된 상태이긴 해요. 또 다른 예시는 양자 상태의 앙상블 개념과 연결돼요.
이건 유한한 양자 상태 집합 위의 확률 분포라고 생각할 수 있어요. 특히, m개의 밀도 행렬 ρ₀부터 ρₘ₋₁까지가 있고,
모두 특정 시스템의 가능한 상태를 나타내며, 각각을 선택할 확률이 있다고 가정해 볼게요.
원한다면 이 밀도 행렬들의 볼록 조합을 취해서 가중 평균을 계산할 수 있어요.
하지만 그렇게 해서는 개별 상태가 무엇인지나 확률이 무엇인지 실제로 알 수 없어요.
대신 할 수 있는 것, 그리고 가끔 매우 유용한 것은, 화면에 나타난 형태의 밀도
행렬을 고려하는 거예요. 이건 두 시스템의 상태인데, 첫 번째 시스템은 각 대안에 대해 하나의 고전적 상태를 가지고,
m개의 곱 상태의 가중 평균을 취해요. 첫 번째 시스템의 상태는 항상 고전적이고,
본질적으로 두 번째 시스템에 대해 m가지 상태 중 어느 것인지를 표시해요.
이런 상태들을 왜 생각하고 싶은지 정확히 명확하지 않아도 괜찮아요. 이건 그냥 첫 번째 시스템이 항상 고전적이고
두 번째 시스템이 양자 상태에 있을 수 있는 유형의 상관관계의 예시예요.
세 번째 범주의 가능한 상관 상태는 소위 분리 가능한
상태의 집합이에요. 간단히 말하면, 이것들은 곱 상태들의 볼록 조합이고, 본질적으로 시스템 간의 상관관계가 고전적 상관관계인 양자 상태를 나타내요.
이런 상태를 생각하는 한 가지 방법은, 숫자 k에 대해 확률적 선택을 하고
그 다음 이 k 선택에 따라 달라질 수 있는 양자 상태에서 두 시스템을 독립적으로 준비하는 거예요.
이 형태의 상태에서 아마도 가장 흥미로운 건, 이게 수학적 용어로 얽힘을 정의하는 방식이라는 거예요.
특히 얽힘은 분리 가능성의 부재로 정의돼요. 따라서 밀도 행렬이 있고 그걸 이런 형태로 표현할 수 없다면,
정의에 의해 얽혀 있는 거예요. 4번 수업에서 이를 암시했고, 이제 조금 더 자세히 알아봤어요.
그런데 주어진 밀도 행렬이 얽힌 상태를 나타내는지 알아내는 건, 컴퓨터의 도움을 받아도 매우 어려울 수 있어요.
수학적으로나 계산적으로도 얽힘은 사실 꽤 복잡해요.
수업 시작 부분에서 밀도 행렬로 할 수 있는 아주 중요한 것을 언급했는데,
그건 다른 시스템과 상관되어 있고 얽혀 있을 수 있는 경우에도 시스템의 고립된 부분의 상태를 설명하는 것이에요.
이 맥락에서 축소 상태라는 용어가 자주 사용돼요. 간단한 예시로, ebit을 형성하는 개별 qubit들의 축소 상태를 계산할 거예요.
정확히 말하면, Alice와 Bob이 ebit을 공유하고,
Alice는 qubit A를, Bob은 qubit B를 가지고 있으며, 이 두 qubit이 함께 Φ+ 상태에 있다고 가정해 볼게요.
그리고 다룰 질문은 고립된 Alice의 qubit A의 상태가 무엇인지예요.
물론 Bob의 qubit에 대해서도 같은 질문을 할 수 있지만, 이 질문의 답을 알면 그 질문은 쉽게 답할 수 있어요.
이제 Alice의 qubit가 Bob의 qubit와 얽혀 있어서 고립된 A의 상태를 설명하거나 심지어 생각하는 것조차 금지될 수 있기 때문에
고립된 Alice의 qubit 상태를 설명할 수 없다고 말하고 싶을 수도 있어요.
하지만 이건 틀렸어요. A의 상태를 양자 상태 벡터로 설명할 수 없는 건 맞아요.
왜냐하면 곧 보게 되듯이 순수 상태가 아니기 때문이에요. 하지만 모든 시스템은 어느 순간이든 밀도 행렬로 설명될 수 있는 상태가 있어요.
다른 시스템과 얽혀 있든 아니든요. 사고 실험으로, 이 질문의 답이 뭔지 파악하는 데 도움을 주기 위해,
Bob이 자신의 qubit을 가지고 별들을 향해 여행을 떠나기로 결정해서 다시는 소식을 못 듣는다고 가정해 볼게요.
하지만 어느 시점에서 그가 자신의 qubit에 표준 기저 측정을 수행하기로 결정한다고 상상해 볼게요.
그럼 그가 두 가지 가능한 결과를 얻을 확률을 어떻게 계산하는지 알고 있어요. 또한 각 가능한 결과에 대해
A의 상태가 무엇이 될지도 알고 있어요. 그것들이 이 표에 요약되어 있어요. 특히 확률 1/2로
A는 0 상태에 남게 되고, 확률 1/2로 A는 1 상태에 남게 돼요.
따라서 수업 초반에 이야기한 것처럼, A는 완전히 혼합된 상태에 있게 돼요. 그래서 그게
우리 질문의 답이에요. 이제 Bob이 자신의 qubit를 측정하기로 결정했다는 사실에 의존하는 것 아니냐고 반론할 수도 있어요.
그가 그렇게 한다는 가정이 이 답으로 이어지는 이야기의 일부라는 것도 맞아요. 하지만
Bob이 측정하는 시점까지 수광년 거리에 있다면, 그가 하는 어떤 것도 Alice가 자신의 qubit에 수행하기로 결정한 어떤 실험에도 영향을 미칠 수 없어요.
그렇지 않으면 빛보다 빠른
통신이 가능해지기 때문이에요. 따라서 Bob이 측정을 하든 안 하든 Alice의 qubit는 완전히 혼합된 상태예요.
이 시점에서 명확히 해야 할 건, 축소 상태의 개념과 그것들이 정의되는 방식은 실제로 상대성 이론이나
빛보다 빠른 통신의 불가능성에 의존하지 않는다는 거예요. 이건 그냥 바라건대 직관적인 용어로 설명하는 방법이에요.
실제로는 수학적 정의가 있고, 잠시 후 더 일반적인 맥락에서 볼 거예요. 그 수학적 정의는 이 답과 일치하고,
우연히 빛보다 빠른 통신의 불가능성과도 일치해요. 그리고 양자 정보에서 알려진 것과 일치할 수 있는 다른 정의도 없어요.
이제 더 일반적인 맥락에서 축소 상태를 고려해 볼게요.
반드시 qubit일 필요는 없는 시스템 A와 B의 쌍이 있고, 양자 상태 벡터 ψ로 표현된 순수 상태에 함께 있다고 가정해 볼게요.
다시 시스템 A의 축소 상태에 집중할 거예요. 그리고 이를 위해 시스템 B의 고전적 상태들을 생각하는 게 유용할 거예요.
γ를 B의 이 고전적 상태 집합이라고 하죠. 예를 들어 시리즈의 2번 수업에서 이야기한 것처럼요.
γ의 각 b에 대해 벡터 φ_b의 고유한 컬렉션이 있어서 화면에 나타난 ψ의 식이 맞아요.
특히 이 벡터들에 대한 간단한 공식이 있어요. 단순히 벡터 ψ에 시스템 A에 해당하는 항등 행렬과
관심 있는 b에 대한 ⟨b|의 텐서 곱을 곱하면 돼요.
여기서 하는 건 기본적으로 시스템 B에 대한 표준 기저 측정을 수행하면 어떻게 되는지 계산할 준비를 하는 거예요.